fierté à son peuple.
Robert Frosi.
♪ ♪ ♪
JEAN-PIERRE ROY, fondateur,
Fédération haïtienne de ski
- C'est plus qu'un rêve,
c'est un truc inimun skieur haïu
même de représenter Haïti dans
olympiques d'hiver.as de
neige. Ce qu'on a, on a le
coeur, on a la foipays
fier. Alors effectivement,
on nous détruit, on nous fait
Et on grimpe les montagnes.
C'est pon ira aux
J.O. à Pékin.
- Je vous sens ému.
Je suis très...
Je suis très ému parce que c'est
tout un travail.
Je sens que ça va aboutir.
♪ ♪ ♪
je pouvais faire en 2010,
après le tremblement de te
pour vraiment qu'on aide Haïti?
Et après, je me suis dit :
le ski. Et je me s
pourquoi pas représenter Haïti
au Championnat du monde?
j'ai reçu la combinaison.
J'ai eu le blouson. C'est Haïti,
en fait. Les gens m'appelaient
Du coup, ils m'ont appelé Rasta
Pourquoi? Parce qu'il y
a Rasta Rockett, ça veut dire
cool dans la luge. Moi, c'es
les piquets, du coup,Rasta Piqu.
♪ ♪ ♪
Tout le monde rigolait, mais moi
dis : mais je ne suis
pas bon skieur, venez me
rejoindre, donc j'ai cherché,
en Europe.On n'a pas de neige c,
donc faut que ce soit forcément
de la diaspora, de viennent
dans l'équipe d'Haïti et de
représenter Haïti.
RICHARDSON VIANO, 1er Haïtiender
- Je suis né à Haïti, à
Port-au-Prince. J'ai été ados ps
montagnards italiens qui vivent.
SILVIA VIANOn
- Haïti a toujours été la terrùt
une maman. Sa maman est morte
pendant qu'il y avait laoption..
Et Haïti n'a jamais été un tabo.
- Le fait d'avoir renoué avec
Haïti, de skierde redevenir
un vrai Haïtien à 100 %.
- C'est la première fois
qu'Haïti sera aux Jeux
olympiqu
- C'est juste impensable.
Si on m'avait dit quand j'étais
représenter Haïti aux Jeux
urais pas cru.
- Et c'est vrai qu'Haïti,
c'est une catastrophe.
on a des trucs et tout.
Je voudrais que le
comprennent que si on veut
donner une image positive du
- L'union fait la force.
- L'unioforce,force,force,force,
mais ça, c'est notre devise.
La diaspora, vous êtes tous là,
on a besoin de voue se
construire. Tous les sportifs
qui veulent représenter Haïti,
C'est possible.
La diaspr. On a ber. On a ber. e
jeunes. Vous, les Canadiens,
j'ai besoin de vous, venez,
venez!
Un petite c'est que j'ai porté
Haïti pendant 10 ans.
équipe, ses valeurs, et en fait
le truc au du mondau du mondau ,
ça va être que je vais être
porte-drapeau. Je vais
le porte-drapeau, voilà.
tous les athlètes qui viendront
ront juste à
côté de moi, derrière moi.
C'est une grande fierté, et
voilà.st un secret.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Aux JO!aller où?
- Aux JO